it doesn't matter what Hollywood is this
doesn't matter and this is one thing
that makes it so great about AGT
you know when I get up there and I'm
always in tears on that show I'm always
because I see the fight that people have
to go through the courage that it takes
to get in front of everyone and put
yourself out there
and then and it's like man and then you
give them something like a golden buzzer
and they're like
oh my God you just gave them a dream
it's better than money it's better than
money because they can do whatever they
want with them especially this year
you're a golden buzzer that kid oh that
was I was crying I'm getting emotional
now yeah I was crying before did you see
his Golden Buzzer
um that kid has just had such a real a
real tough time and was incredibly
articulate sadly about his feelings
about not being worthy and thinking
about suicide and
um just how tough his life is so to be
witness in that room to
um he said he said we said what does the
show mean to you or what does this mean
to you before he got the golden buzzer
before he played he said I think that
this is you know and I think that most
people go through life going what is my
purpose why am I here he thought this is
why he's here if he does okay today this
is why this is my purpose and his mom
made him go too right he didn't even
sign yeah it was his mom it was his mom
yeah his mom made and she was standing
you were standing standing right there
with a dude and again
when I just look at what this is because
I don't I you know
it's really not you know who's to say
one singer is better than a sax player
that's better than a dancer you can't
it's objective you know what I mean
you're right but all you have to do is
go out there and give your all see
because in comparison it's like well was
I good enough but when you just
deal with what you have and just enjoy
what you have and that's what we when
you see somebody out there enjoying what
they have you just gotta I'm like man
that's how I have to live like I every I
get reminded all the time man enjoy what
you have dude stop looking at what
everybody else got and then comparing
start looking at what you have and
listen and every time I do that I get I
go home and I go holy cow man
I almost lost all this
[Music]